welcome back Julian Assange faces
extradition to the United States after
his arrest this week and his case is
causing some political waves as well
with the Home Secretary likely to be
involved in deciding where he ends up
well we're joined now by Jennifer
Robinson mr. Assange is lawyer thank you
very much for being on the program this
morning Emily
a lot of our viewers will be looking at
this and thinking this is a man who's
been hiding from justice for seven years
why should he be above the law he's not
above the law and the fact is he's never
been concerned about facing British
justice or indeed Swedish justice this
case is and has always been about his
concern about being sent to face
American injustice we've been warning
since 2010 and I've been working on his
case since the initial Swedish request
came through we've been warning since
then that he would face the risk of US
extradition for actions and his work
associated with WikiLeaks publications
we warned for years and that is
precisely what has happened he was right
all along a we were right all along to
be worried about it he was granted
asylum inside the Ecuadorian Embassy
because of his concern about this risk
of on what extradition to the United
States he has always cooperated with the
Swedish investigation he remained in
Sweden to answer questions we offered
his testimony before they sought his
extradition and we continued to offer
his testimony he only sought asylum
inside the Ecuadorian Embassy when
Sweden refused to give assurances about
onward extradition to the United States
that was what he was concerned about he
offered his testimony from inside the
embassy the Ecuadorian government sought
assurances from Sweden he wouldn't be
sent to the u.s. those assurances were
not forthcoming and let's not forget
that he actually opted questions of the
prosecutors years ago and that was when
they decided to drop the investigation
in Sweden so there is there have been no
charges in Sweden he offered his
testimony and they decided to drop the
case okay when they dropped the case he
didn't leave the embassy so if he had
been all these people saying he was
hiding from Swedish justice if that were
the case why didn't he walk out of the
embassy two years ago when this case was
dropped okay well let's try and unpick
some of what you're saying here because
it's quite complex story and we're
talking now about some of the Swedish
allegations really serious allegations
rape sexual assault he of course denies
them and and you say that it's all about
him wanting worrying about being
extradited to the US but at the same
time
it was the extradition to Sweden which
was why he went into the embassy in the
first place
because the UK agreed with the
extradition to Sweden two weeks later he
went into the embassy I mean it was the
u.s. wasn't on the table at that point
we work in there was a grand jury
investigation that was opened back in
2010 and we were concerned about the
risk of US extradition then that concern
has been proven correct this week here
in Sweden to face those allegations we
were concerned because Sweden had not
provided the assurance against onward
extradition that once in custody once in
custody he would not be able to seek
asylum with respect to the United States
that is why he walked into the embassy
when he did the asylum that was granted
by Ecuador was with respect to the risk
of being sent to the United States to
face prosecution for his publishing
activities and for actions associated
with that that is precisely the request
that came through this week now
Ecuador continued to negotiate with
Sweden to try to deal with the Swedish
investigation and to allow prosecutors
to question him so he could answer the
Swedish allegations while protecting him
from US extradition that is why he was
in the embassy you see you say that he
provided testimony that he's answered
the allegations in Sweden but it's on
his terms isn't it I mean what does that
mean offer testa me does that just mean
writing a letter to Sweden there's a lot
of people that's not appropriate
the Swedish prosecutors came inside the
Ecuadorian Embassy to ask him questions
about the case he gave his testimony and
after that they chose to close the
investigation this is a fact that has
been completely lost in the discussion
about this case over the past couple of
weeks that investigation was closed
after hearing his testimony if they
choose to reopen it that is a separate
question and we will deal with it but we
are absolutely happy to answer those
queries if and when they come up the key
issue at the moment is US extradition
which is what we've warned about for
many years because my understanding was
that the charges were dropped
effectively because he was in the
embassy so the rape investigation
dropped in 2017 because they couldn't
formally notify him of the allegations
to molestation charges dropped in 2015
because time had run out because he was
effectively in the embassy for seven
years so he didn't have to face up to it
that's what lots of people will be
thinking he as all as I've said
repeatedly he has always offered his
testimony and offered to cooperate with
the Swedish but it says no it's not what
they want in order to protect himself
from the very extradition request that
was served on
him this week he was right to be
concerned about that and that is why he
was in the embassy this case is and has
always been about the risk of
extradition to the United States I think
people need to focus on the fact that
these this indictment that has come from
the United States relates to his
communications with a source about a
major public interest publication this
is about Chelsea Manning's leak in 2010
this is about us spying on UN and
European politicians this is about human
rights abuse and corruption the world
over this is about evidence of US war
crimes killing journalists these are the
publications that he is now facing
extradition and prosecution over it's
also about rape allegations and women
who have who feel that they haven't seen
those allegations been brought to
justice an investigation in Sweden which
he cooperated with while protecting
himself from extradition to the United
States if if that investigation is
reopened if there is an extradition
request we will deal with it and we can
tie with an extradition request if it is
made by Sweden if Sweden makes an
extradition request there will be a
question for the Home Secretary about
which case will take precedence and we
will certainly be asking for the same
assurances that we asked before which is
that he wouldn't be sent to the United
States after dealing with it that is the
same assurance we were seeking in 2010
and the refusal to give that is why he
sought asylum was so otherwise he won't
he doesn't want to comply with it unless
there is that specific assurance the
concern is and has always been about
protecting him from being sent to the
United States okay well let's talk about
the u.s. extradition request and the
argument seems to be that this is a
journalist concerned with transparency
and that it was a public interest
defense but the US charge is quite
specific isn't it it's about hacking
into a computer system now if if anybody
actually reads beyond the the headline
of the Department of Justice press
release which is about hacking if you
look at the actual factual allegations
what it boils down to
he's an allegation that he was
communicating with a source encouraging
a source to provide information and
provided alleged allegedly provided
information to assist the source to
protect their identity so Chelsea
Manning there's no suggestion that
joined the Sanj hacked US government
computers there's no suggestion that he
assisted Chelsea Manning to access
material that Chelsea Manning didn't
already have access to
it is simply an allegation of an
intention to assist a source to protect
their identity while accessing that
material this is something that
journalists do all the time now it
remains to be seen whether those
allegations can be proven but that's why
u.s. free speech groups have been up in
arms this week and are very concerned
about the chilling impact this will have
because it clearly this indictment
clearly engages news gathering
activities and the kinds of
communications that journalists have
with sources all the time other human
rights groups they had been concerned
about some of the actions that WikiLeaks
had taken with regards to that material
as well I'm referring to for example the
fact that Amnesty International and
Reporters Without Borders said that the
Taliban could use some of the data that
he made public in order to try and
target Afghan civilians who worked with
the u.s. coalition effectively putting
their lives at risk I mean what's the
journalistic justification for that
well journalists published information
all the time which which is alleged by
government officials to potentially put
at risk national security or put people
at risk but there is no let's take steps
to try there to make sure that civilians
are protected as well that's true where
WikiLeaks also had a reduction process
in the early days when they were doing
the publication's with the Guardian and
you know there were some issues around
around that but the fact is there's
constant allegations that WikiLeaks has
somehow caused damage to people there is
no evidence that anybody has been harmed
or certainly not killed as a result of
WikiLeaks publications not no evidence
of that I guess and I'm trying to get to
a little bit as well and with the first
question about some people think this is
a man who sees themselves above the law
is that I can understand that you have
question marks over the US justice
system but mr. Assange also doesn't want
to face the swedish courts he can also
appeal in the UK to the supreme court
against the extradition he can also
appeal to the European Court of Human
Rights so why doesn't he trust any of
these courts in the US the European
Court the UK called Swedish call the
concern was not about facing Swedish
justice and I'll say it again it was not
about he's concerned about facing
Swedish justice it was the risk of
facing American injustice now this case
is highly politicized if we look back to
2010 which is what the indictment
relates to we had high-profile US
politicians calling for him to be killed
by drone strike we've we've seen just
this week
while senators saying that he's now our
property and will do within what we will
these are serious concerns and if we
look at the way that you think the UK
government's personal sizing it as well
then I think this case has been
politicized now we will obviously fight
this actually the exhibition requests
the United States in the court so it's a
matter for the British courts now but in
terms of the broader context this is
somebody who has published the largest
amount of American classified
information in history he has
demonstrated he's embarrassed the US
military industrial complex he's
embarrassed the CIA we've had the
director of the CIA call him a hostile
non non state intelligence agency and
saying that he ought to be prosecuted we
want to take WikiLeaks down and he ought
not benefit from First Amendment
protections these are very serious
allegations from the highest level of
the US administration and to think that
this case is not politicized I think he
ignores the fact he has had some Pisco
support from Jeremy Corbyn who tweeted
to say that he doesn't think he should
be extradited to the US was that welcome
of course it's welcome and I think that
anyone who believes in Public Interest
journalism and understands the public
interest in the publication's that
WikiLeaks made like I said spying on you
UN leaders spying on European
politicians spying on the French
president the WikiLeaks publications
included material that Amnesty
International credited wikileaks from
tunisia that sparked the Arab Spring and
democratic revolutions it's changed the
way we think about journalism and the
right to know
having someone extradited for any
actions associated with those
publications that have one journalism
awards the world over ought to be a
concern that's right and correct that
Jeremy Corbyn said what he said and just
finally this is a man who spent seven
years in a room at the Ecuadorian
Embassy and we've all seen the footage
of him emerging from the Ecuadorian
embassy a lot of allegations of rumors
over the relationship breakdown
including that he's feces on the walls I
mean what is it in like for him living
in there I think the first thing to say
is that Ecuador has been making some
pretty outrageous allegations over the
past few days to justify what was an
unlawful and extraordinary act and
allowing British police to come inside
an embassy so it's not true that's not
true look it's a difficult situation
I've been visiting him in the embassy
for
throughout this seven-year period its he
hasn't had outside access to the outside
he's been inside a room effectively as
you said for more than seven years
people have children who are six and
seven years old for that for your
child's entire life this man has been
inside a room in quite difficult
circumstances
now the politics of the case with
respect to Ecuador change with the
change of government with Luna Mourinho
coming to power and ever since then
inside the embassy it's become more and
more difficult to the point where even
Human Rights Watch said it was akin to
solitary confinement so he's had a very
difficult time it's not been easy and to
suggest that someone would choose to
remain in there without legitimate
concerns about US extradition which is
exactly what was proven this week I
think people can't really understand
what it would be like to live in a room
like that for a very long time it's not
been easy okay thank you very much for
being on the program tonight